i mean this is it is just phenomenal as
we know
uh a lot of the people in the urban
community the black community do not
trust the vaccine and i wouldn't either
because of the tuskegee experiment and
many of the other problems
uh we have not i mean can we say this
the us government has not been good to
the black people
is that are we allowed to say that so
many of them are
inherently skeptical of the vaccine so
as in outreach
to that uh our government who has spent
uh
years and years and years lying to uh
people of color
and uh putting them in jail for no
reason and all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
um they have an
urban uh an outreach to people
and and this is somebody trying to make
me the vaccine
during the pandemic my lifestyle
drastically changed my income came to a
screeching halt you have to understand
i'm a hustler i'm a legit entrepreneur i
sell things
i come in contact with people all the
time i have to stay safe
i didn't have a choice but to trust her
back why does this seem racist
do you understand what i mean why do i
start to cringe when he's like i'm a
hustler i sell thanks
what are we doing here who in arkansas
thought this was a good idea i'm a
hustler i sell things i'm not going to
say what i sell
it's not my it's not your business i
make [ __ ] happen i know a guy it's like
why are we what is this
what is going on here first of all it's
also a bad idea because if you're not a
hustler or an entrepreneur
you go i don't need it right you're
trying to
like broaden the scope of people you
want to get it what if there's a guy who
goes
i'm not an entrepreneur at all i work at
little caesars
i don't need it but it seems racist and
i don't know why but let's finish it up
all right
let's start it over because it's insane
during the pandemic my lifestyle
drastically changed
my income came to a screeching halt you
have to understand i'm a hustler i'm a
legitimate
other way what car is he
old ford mustang it's an old ford
mustang now he's outside of the building
we don't know where
we don't know what that building is
t-r-o-i-s
that's the end of the bit we don't know
but he's just posted up on an old ford
mustang
in a parking lot
being an entrepreneur he's not at a desk
he's not in an office
they didn't put him in an office the
state of arkansas
did not put him in office they didn't
put him in a suit they didn't put him
anywhere near a place of business
he's in a parking lot on a ford mustang
giving you advice about the vaccine
continue
doing the pandemic my lifestyle
drastically changed my income came to a
screeching halt you have to understand
i'm a hustler i'm a legit entrepreneur i
sell things what do you do i come in
contact with people all the time what's
your job to stay safe
i didn't have a choice but to trust the
vaccine if you live the type of
lifestyle that i live
during what you're out here in these
streets entrepreneur
why not do it safely if you're out here
in these streets
hustling why not do it safely
what is your job
what job description is quote out here
in these streets
this is from the arkansas department of
health
what career
is described as i'm quote hustling
out here in these streets they're making
them seem like a drug dealer
this is literally saying if you are also
a drug dealer
get the vaccine i mean that's literally
what it's saying
they're going hey if you sell drugs you
may not think it's important to get the
vaccine
but you should
there is by the way there is no attempt
to make this guy seem like he has a job
that anyone would understand as legit
his his job description is if you are
out here hustling in these streets
selling things and coming into contact
with people all the time
get the vaccine what may i ask
are you doing in these streets
i mean let's let's go through this again
i i
can almost not believe this start over
okay are you sure we're not being
trolled this is real
yeah let's let's just double check here
because they were playing it before
youtube videos yet
i was seeing it played before youtube
videos as ads so
yeah and they've turned the comments off
i wonder why they've done that
and it says right here on youtube from
state public health authority
jesus that's crazy okay keep going this
is hilarious okay
during the pandemic my lifestyle
drastically changed my income came to a
screeching halt you have to understand
i'm a hustler i'm a legit entrepreneur i
sell things
i come in contact with people all the
time i have to stay safe
i didn't have a choice but to trust the
vaccine if you live the type of
lifestyle that i live
you're out here in these streets and
you're hustling an entrepreneur like me
why not do it safely so i want everybody
to take this seriously
take a shot at staying healthy take a
shot
wouldn't it be funny if he it was like a
gang war at the end that's the weird
take a shot like should he even like
take a shot just like that with the gun
like right to the camera
it seems odd i don't believe we're
getting troll because youtube like
has anyone talked about this at all i
saw it go somewhat viral on twitter
uh yeah but other than i found it on
youtube and it played before people's
youtube ads they were screen recording
it and like sharing it on tiktok and
twitter
god